Die 2. Liga, sie ist spannend wie eigentlich immer. Und wir wollen heute nicht nur auf den Stand in der Liga blicken, sondern nochmal genauer auf den FC St. Pauli, auf Wehen-Wiesbaden und auf den 1. FC Kaiserslautern. Und das tun wir mit Moritz Kreilinger, Sonja Riegel und Tim Eckstein jetzt hier im Rasenfunk. Ich freu mich! 30 Spieltage sind gespielt. Es wird richtig ernst in der 2. Liga. Es ist wieder einiges passiert. Höchste Zeit für eine neue Ausgabe der Ligatur, zu der ich euch ganz herzlich begrüße, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodom.social und bei Gloosgeil und ich begrüße jetzt bei mir zum einen Moritz Kreilinger. Moritz, schön, dass du mal wieder da bist. Dann ist Tim Eckstein hier. Hallo Tim.
Das ist die Frage.
Etwas sarkastisch könnten wir jetzt sagen, so den Trainer, den der FCK jetzt bräuchte, der steht eh noch auf der Gehaltsliste. Das wäre vielleicht so ein Dirk Schuster.
Ja, ich meine, also ich finde es halt interessant, es gibt ja bei Teams auch immer, wenn ich das so mitbekomme, gibt es halt diese Überlegung, auch diese Rechnung, macht man das jetzt? Oder überlegt man, ob man es in die Relegation schafft und macht man das dann vor der Relegation, um neue Impulse zu setzen? Oder, oder, oder? Und ich finde das halt spannend, weil für mich, so wie du das beschreibst, liegen halt alle – alles spricht gegen Funkel eigentlich gerade. Also es ist wirklich so, dass ich, also so wie du das beschreibst, es ist, sehe ich nichts, was jetzt dafür sprechen sollte. Man muss an diesen Trainer festhalten, außer er ist schon der dritte Trainer in der Saison. Aber das ist ja eigentlich kein Argument.
Es spricht aber ehrlich gesagt auch alles gegen Thomas Hengen. Also auf der einen Seite hast du die Trainerentscheidung, auf der anderen Seite gucken wir uns den Kader an und sagen, wir sind schief.
Dazu kommt aber jetzt halt so ein bisschen der Background in Kaiserslautern. Die regionale Investorengruppe, die diesen Verein ja durch jährliche Millionenschübe am Leben erhält, die hat ja doch mehr zu sagen, als ihr vielleicht rein Statuten auf dem Papier an Stimmen zustehen.
So was gibt es im deutschen Fußball? Ich dachte, die äußern ihre Meinung immer nur zu 49 Prozent.
Ja, und da wird dann auch ein gehöriges Wort mitgesprochen. Und ich sag mal so, das Ganze soll jetzt nicht despektierlich klingen, aber für Leute, die da nicht unbedingt die Fußballaffinsten oder zumindest Insider der Branche sind, für die ist dann Friedhelm Funkel in so einer Situation auch ein toller Name. Also das zieht dann mehr als jetzt – ich will jetzt keine Namen nennen, aber ihr wisst genau so, der klassische Zweiliegerfeuer wäre man jetzt noch mal so.
Ich meine, Friedhelm Funkel hat auf jeden Fall Geschichten, die er erzählen kann, aus seiner Zeit bei Köln und so weiter und so fort und in vielen, vielen Jahrzehnten vorher eigentlich. Und gleichzeitig hat man ja diese absurde Situation, dass man im DFB-Pokalfinale steht und ich schon von prominenten FCK-Fans wie Thomas Schmidt bis hin zu weniger prominenten sieht man alle nur in der Warteschlange hängen für Final-Tickets. Und das wird ja auch das Highlight dieser Saison sein und könnte aber gleichzeitig halt rund um eine Relegation gestrickt sein. Und das wäre ja schon eines der Positiv-Szenarien, dass man es immerhin in die Relegation geschafft hat. Wie blickst du denn darauf? Ehrlicherweise wäre es ja nach allem, was ich vom FCK gelernt habe in den Jahren, in denen ich Fußball-Fan bin, seit Anfang der 90er bis jetzt, würde das ja total gut zum FCK passen, dass man einerseits da wahrscheinlich dann sogar ein ganz gutes Finale spielt, von Gewinnen will ich jetzt nicht reden, ehrlicherweise, und gleichzeitig aber in der Relegation runtergeht.
Ja, ich glaube tatsächlich die Außenseiterrolle. Und Kaiserslautern hat häufig in Außenseiterrollenspiele gewonnen, aber ich glaube so aufsichtslos wie dieses Mal war die Ausgangslage nie. Und genau darin sehe ich so ein bisschen die Gefahr, dass diese Mannschaft, die ist ja auch mental oder im Kopf so. Jan Elwedi hat in der Winterpause – kurzer Blick zurück – einmal gesagt, wir sind ja eigentlich viel besser, als wie wir in der Tabelle da stehen. Und damals war der FCK, ich glaube, 13. 14. also was bei weitem nicht so brenzlig wie jetzt. Und das ist so ein bisschen das Problem mit dieser Denkweise. Diese Mannschaft denkt, sie ist viel besser und sie zeigt es auch immer mal wieder. Hat es ja in dieser ganzen DFB-Pokalreise gezeigt. Ich nehme jetzt mal das Halbfinale gegen Saarbrücken raus, das war wirklich unterirdisch. Aber ich glaube, dass einfach der Fokus von vielen dann auf dem DFB-Pokalfinale liegt und nicht auf einer möglichen Relegation. Auch weil viele einfach in dieser Mannschaft drin sind, die doch nicht so lange da sind, die jetzt nicht die totale Identifikation mit dem FCK haben, wie jetzt zum Beispiel ein George Zimmer oder auch wie ein Marlon Ritter inzwischen, die dieses FCK-Gen leben und die wissen, was es bedeutet, wenn der FCK absteigt in die 3. Liga, weil die haben beide schon mit dem FCK 3. Liga gespielt. Und für andere ist vielleicht aber dieses DFB-Pokalspiel so das absolute Highlight. Hey, du hast 90 Minuten und kannst DFB-Pokalsieger werden. Das ist für die meisten oder vielleicht für alle in dieser Mannschaft eine einmalige Chance. Und wir wissen ja, wie das ist, wenn im Kopf nur 5% fehlen irgendwie und irgendwie das Relegationsspiel wäre ja dann Mittwochs das erste. Und wenn nur 5% der Gedanken schon auf den Samstagabend in Berlin schauen, dann könnte es ein sehr teures Pokalfinale werden, in diesem Sinne. Oder wie schaut ihr denn von außen da drauf? Wird mich jetzt auch mal interessieren.
Sonja, du wolltest ja eh was ergänzen.
Ich wollte ja eh was ergänzen und zwar nicht auf dieses Jahr, sondern ich würde sehr weit zurückgehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Max sich als Bayern-Fan vielleicht noch daran erinnert. 2006 das Pokalfinale, weil jetzt erzähle ich nämlich damit Funkel nicht immer selber von früher erzählen muss, erzähle ich jetzt von Friedhelm Funkel von früher, als er mit der Eintracht ja auch im Abstiegskampf war und auch ins Pokalfinale gekommen ist und das quasi vorab schon abgeschenkt hat, also zumindest verbal. Also immer ja ja, Abstiegskampf ist wichtiger und so. Das hatte aber damals diese dumme Besonderheit, dass das vor Saisonende gespielt wurde wegen WM und so. Und dann war das so ein paar Wochen vor Saisonende und dann war das einfach so dahergeschenkt. Weil also Liga ist wichtiger, Liga ist wichtiger und ich fand das auch ein bisschen doof. Ich dachte also der Titel ist wichtiger. Hallo, steigst ab, steigst wieder auf. So ungefähr. Natürlich so einfach ist es nicht, aber das ist das, was du so als Anhängersicht dann ja doch irgendwie drin hast. Und deswegen kann ich das schon verstehen, weil als Spielersicht wahrscheinlich auch. Ich mein, im Zweifel wechselst du in einen Verein und spielst weiter, zweite Liga oder wie auch immer und hast aber dann da stehen, du bist Pokalsieger. Deswegen kann ich das aus Spielersicht verstehen. Ich kann es irgendwie auch aus Fansicht verstehen, dass man sagt, boah, Titel wäre schon geil. Und abgestiegen sind wir jetzt so oft, dann sind wir auch wieder aufgestiegen. Aber klar, für einen Verein an sich, irgendwie als Entscheidungsträger im Verein darf man das nicht so sehen. Da würde ich auch nicht wollen, dass das so jemand dann so sieht. Aber jetzt ist die Konstellation ja ein bisschen anders, erst nach der Saison.
Ja, aber zwar ja zwischen den Relegationsspielen, also im Grunde doch mitten der Saison, also falls sie Relegation spielen.
Wird es tatsächlich nicht verschoben?
Also die Relegation wird verschoben, aber Relegation wird dann Mittwoch-Mittwoch gespielt. Also Mittwoch-Gemmelspiel, Samstag-Pokalfinale, Mittwoch-Rückspiel.
Na dann passt meine Funkeltheorie. Dann macht er das wie damals, das passt schon.
Damals feife es an der Hand von Oli Kahn. Das war sie noch. 87. Minute Schuss von einem Frankfurter. Das wäre es 2-2, glaube ich, gewesen.
Das 1-1. Und dann hat er den ganzen Block beleidigt. Da hat er sich umgedreht und alle beleidigt.
Ja, Oli Kahn. Und wer hätte damals gedacht, dass er der vernünftigere von den beiden zur WM 2006 mitfahrenend Torhüter tritt.
Das führt jetzt zu weit.
Das führt wirklich zu weit. Aber wäre das nicht eigentlich auch ein Anlass, Moritz, für die Fans, den Spielern, bei denen das ja nachvollziehbarer Weise wirklich so sein könnte, dass man auf dieses Highlight-DFB-Pokal ein bisschen zu sehr jetzt schon blickt, denen eben das zu vermitteln, was das bedeutet, für den FCK zu spielen und jetzt auch in Heimspielen zu spielen. Und ich meine das jetzt nicht in bedrohender Art und Weise. Das finde ich immer sehr schwierig. Ich kann mich auch erinnern an das Auspfeifen lassen des Teams von Milan Džaržić. Allerdings haben mir bisher Spieler immer gesagt, das bringt einem ehrlich gesagt gar nichts, wenn einen 50.000 Leute beschimpfen. Weil man weiß schon selber vorher, dass man schlecht gespielt hat. Aber im Positiven wäre es ja möglich. Und das haben wir doch auch schon häufig genug erlebt, dass dann eben 8.000 Fans zum Training kommen und noch mal einstimmen. Jetzt auf das Spiel in Kiel, dann auf das Heimspiel gegen Magdeburg. Müsste sich nicht vielleicht das Umfeld selber aus der Letter G rausziehen können?
Ja, die Kraft sollte das, also die Kraft rein mengenmäßig, sollte das Umfeld ja auf jeden Fall haben. Aber auch in der Fangemeinde sehe ich sehr gespaltene Meinungen über dieses Thema. Weil halt viele, die vielleicht das große Ganze, auch das ganze Wirtschaftliche und alle Folgen jetzt nicht überblicken, auch denken, ja klar, lass uns DFB-Pokal-Sieger werden, steigen wir halt ab, steigen wir halt wieder auf. Aber jeder, der sich intensiver mit diesem Verein beschäftigt, weiß einfach, wie dramatisch es wäre, wenn die noch mal runtergehen. Weil der FCK hat erst letzte Woche auf LinkedIn einen Beitrag darüber gepostet, wie der EV wieder personell aufgestellt ist. Die sind irgendwie statt einem Festangestellten sind es jetzt wieder sechs oder sieben. Und was hätte denn einen Abstieg zur Folge? Im Endeffekt, dass du wieder sechs Leute im EV rausschmeißen musst. Und jetzt in der KGAA gar nicht erst angefangen. Da müsstest du auch wieder diverse Stellen streichen. Und selbst wenn wir jetzt sagen, dieser irre Fall, die gewinnen den Pokal, dann hast du halt irgendwie für ein Jahr Europapokal einen an. Gut, dann kannst du das ein Jahr, kannst du das wieder auffedern. Aber wie schwer tun sich Absteiger in der dritten Liga? Wie schwer tun die sich? Und wenn du dann nicht direkt im ersten Jahr wieder hochgehst, dann kommt die Entlassungswelle halt im zweiten Jahr. Und der FCK war bei seinem letzten Drittliga-Aufenthalt mit einem Bein in der Regionalliga. Und wer weiß, ob es nicht nächstes Jahr, also wenn es passiert, nicht dann diesen Schritt geht und dann irgendwie irgendwie ein 1860 wird und ewig da unten bleibt oder ein MSV Duisburg wird, der ja jetzt leider sich auch aus dieser Liga nach unten verabschiedet hat. Es kann für diesen Verein in erster Linie nur um den Klassenerhalt gehen. Aber klar, was machst du? Du kannst ja auch nicht vorher ein Pokalfinale abschenken. Du kannst ja nicht ein Pokalfinale mit einer B-Mannschaft auflaufen lassen. Es ist eine super schwierige Gemengelage und ich will da auch nicht in der Haut der Verantwortlichen stecken, wenn es dann tatsächlich zu dieser wirklich undankbaren Konstellation kommt.
Ja, aber andererseits ist es doch eigentlich einfach. Fünf Spiele, eventuell sieben Spiele Vollgas geben. Und das muss von jedem Spieler verlangbar sein. Und wer es nicht leisten kann, der spielt da nicht. Das muss vom Trainer. Kann man das verlangen, dass er es auch schafft, das zu transportieren, das Umfeld anzuzünden. Und von den Fans kann man es auch erwarten, dass die jetzt alles dafür tun. Meine Güte, das ist ja – also man ist ein Punkt zum Relegationsplatz, zwei zum Nicht-Abstiegsplatz. Ich meine, wir reden hier fast schon in so einem Graveston über Lautern. Aber ey, ist doch noch alles drin. Das muss doch möglich sein. Und da darf man doch auch nicht – also das DFB-Pokalfinale darf da doch auch keinerlei Entschuldigung sein. Seid froh, dass ihr irgendwie da hingekommen seid gegen Saarbrücken. Gut, Klammer drum ist, egal, wie man ins Pokalfinale kommt, ist ja auch eine super Geschichte und ist ja sogar mal ein Zeitpunkt, an dem wirklich große Teile Deutschlands sicherlich dem Außenseiter die Daumen drücken werden. Aber jetzt erst mal vier Spiele und vielleicht halt sechs Spiele Vollgas.
Was noch dazu kommt zu dieser dann ja extremen oder vermehrten Belastung jetzt noch mit sieben Spielen mit englischen Wochen? Ragnar Ache hat anfangs dieser Woche wieder nicht trainiert. Ich meine, es waren jetzt achile Szenenbeschwerden. Und jeder weiß, ich hatte es in seiner letzten Verletzungsperiode ausgerechnet. Ich habe die Zahlen nicht mal im Kopf. Aber irgendwie der Punkteschnitt, wenn Ragnar Ache nicht gespielt hat, war bei 0, 1, 0, 2 irgendwas. Und der Punkteschnitt, wenn Ragnar Ache getroffen hat, war irgendwo bei 1, 6, 1, 7. Nagelt mich nicht fest so irgendwie in dem Dreh. Wenn der dieser Mannschaft im Saisonfinale in einer Relegation, wo auch immer, fehlen sollte, dann hilft nur noch beten.
Es war so klar nach der letzten Saison, die immer so halbwegs ereignislos war, zumindest in lauterer Maßstämme, war so klar, dass wieder so eine ganz normale jetzt kommen würde.
Aber ich meine, diese Delle, die hat man ja letzte Rückrunde schon gesehen. Und ich verstehe immer nicht, wie, also ich meine, da ging es ja damals auch um Demut und zu erkennen, okay, das war jetzt, wir haben die Welle, die Aufstiegswelle sozusagen gut abgeritten, vielleicht ein bisschen besser als der Kader vielleicht auch ist und sind dann ein bisschen abgeschmiert in der Rückrunde. Aber wir können haben irgendwie die Chance, uns zu etablieren in der 2. Liga. Und ich meine, diese Negativspirale, die ist ja einfach über den Sommer weitergegangen gefühlt. Und da hat sich ja nicht viel dran geändert dann. Aber es kommt ja immer wieder auf diesen Punkt dieser Schuster-Entlassung drauf eigentlich. Also weil das ja für so eine Art Ideenlosigkeit widerspiegelt oder anzeigt dann, wenn man das Gefühl hat, okay, wir wollen hier was bewegen, dann kannst du eigentlich nach der Rückrunde der letzten Saison musst du sagen, ja okay, wir wollen was bewegen. Dann kommst du aber mit Schuster auch vielleicht gar nicht weiter, sondern dann musst du vielleicht einen ganz größeren Umbruch denken. Dann gehst du in die Saison mit Schuster. Es läuft genauso wie dann in der Vor-Saison in der Rückrunde. Ich meine, was hast du auch erwartet, wenn du da so weitermachst? Und dann schmeißt du den raus. Die Verwunderung darüber, dass Kaiserslautern so abschmiert, die teile ich nicht so. Auch wenn ich natürlich gesehen habe, dass das mit Gramozis natürlich echt gar nicht zusammengelaufen ist, dass das super krass gewesen ist. Aber diese Negativspirale, die läuft halt schon seit 16 Monaten oder so.
Du hast halt – ich will die Zeit hier, wir sind ja eh schon drüber, gar nicht unendlich sprengen.
Aber es ist so spannend, der Wiedergang von Kaiserslautern. Also ich label da nicht dran, sondern es ist einfach spannend zu sehen, wie so ein Club, bei dem eigentlich so vieles vorhanden ist, um sich wirklich ja doch irgendwie eher in eine andere Richtung zu bewegen, wie das so weggeworfen werden kann, so gefühlt.
Du hast halt nach dem Aufstieg eine Verkettung von Fehlentscheidungen getroffen. Es lief nach dem Aufstieg sportlich wieder gut zunächst, aber der ganze Verein hat sich nicht wieder an die 2. Liga angepasst. Dass du weiterhin mit Thomas Hengen nur einen einzigen Geschäftsführer hast, das ist einfach zu wenig. Im Grunde, wenn du den entlässt, stehst du wieder völlig führungslos da. Es ist eigentlich der Plan schon länger, auch aus diversen Gremien wird es gefordert, dass du dich breiter aufstellst, dass du einen Geschäftsführungsposten auch auf der kaufmännischen Ebene wieder einführst. Das ist so viel, was im Hintergrund einfach nicht läuft. Dann diese – ich muss das wirklich als ominöse Einstellung von Enes Hayri als technischem Direktor bezeichnen, der ja im Grunde die Transfergeschäfte inzwischen erledigt und wirklich auch mit Dirk Schuster konnte er nicht, mit großen Teilen der Mannschaft konnte er nicht, es sind zahlreiche fragwürdige Transfers. Es ist irgendwie, Thomas Hengen hatte in seinen ersten zwei Jahren in Kaiserslautern wirklich ein sehr gutes Händchen, was Spieler angeht, was Trainer anging und dieses Händchen hat er seit dem Aufstieg bzw. dann seit der Rückrunde nach dem Aufstieg einfach völlig verloren und der FCK fällt irgendwie wieder in dieses Muster zurück, das ihn in den letzten zehn Jahren diesen sportlichen Niedergang gekostet hat.
Ich glaube, dieses letzte Segment, das kann man all denjenigen vorspielen, die vielleicht auch aus guten Gründen darüber weinen, dass sich jetzt mit Köln wieder wahrscheinlich ein Traditionsverein aus der ersten Liga verabschiedet und dann vielleicht mit Heustern Kiel nicht die Tradition per se hochkommt. Ich finde, es gibt valide Argumente, sich darüber zu ärgern. Aber wenn man sich die Frage stellt, warum schaffen es denn Traditionsvereine öfter nicht, schaut euch an, was der 1. Läufte Köln diese Saison gemacht hat und in der Transferperiode, in denen sie noch was machen durften, hört euch an, was wir gerade über Lautern gesprochen haben. Und ich weiß, dass Moritz, Hayri, alleine dazu könntest du jetzt noch eine Stunde was erzählen. Du hast es ja schon mal hier angedeutet und so weiter und so fort. Ich werde den letzten Schwerpunkt auch nochmal verlinken.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, damals habe ich doch eine halbe Stunde über ihn gesprochen.
Genau. Und es war genauso unterhaltsam. Ich meine, immerhin, das ist immer da. Der 1. Läufte Köln ist quasi das Popcorn-Emoji als Verein. Es ist immer was los. Und wie es ausgeht, sehen wir dann. Ich bin ultra – ich bin jetzt richtig hyped wieder auf den nächsten Spieltag, muss ich sagen. Ich bin so gespannt, wie das alles ausgeht, wie sich Wehen-Wiesbaden schlägt, was jetzt Rostock macht, ob Kaiserslautern uns nicht vielleicht doch auch positiv überrascht, ob es noch irgendjemanden da unten reinzieht, der jetzt glaubt, er ist schon weg. Der Theorie nach schon auch noch möglich. Ich bin gespannt. Ich weiß, dass ihr drei es auch seid. Aber ich bin erstmal sehr froh, dass ich euch drei hier hatte. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Moritz Kreilinger vom Kicker. Danke dir, Moritz.
Ja, danke für die Einladung. War wie immer schön bei euch.
Aber wirklich, obwohl wir über den FTK sprechen mussten. Danke an Tim Exdin vom Millenton, den ihr natürlich auch alle abonniert und hört als Podcast und als Blog und so weiter und so fort. Danke dir, lieber Tim.
Ja, danke. Es tut mir leid. Ich hab das am Anfang in meiner Euphorie auch gar nicht so so kommen sehen, dass wir uns danach noch eine 50 Minuten über Abstiegs-Sorgen unterhalten. Und ich vielleicht mit meiner guten Laune hier vielleicht eher so ein bisschen, ein bisschen viel am Platz bin vielleicht.
Das war schon so gewollt, dass wir hier quasi Aufstieg und möglicherweise Abstieg rein machen. Und ich sehe ja, dass die anderen ja auch gute Laune haben. Die können ja nichts für die Vereine über diese berichten. So ja auch Sonja Riege, bei der ich mich besonders bedanke, Sonja, dass du dir so kurz vor dem ESC noch Zeit genommen hast. Alle, die uns bei YouTube sehen, die sehen schon, dass du schon voll drauf eingestellt bist. Bei BleistiftRocker.de schreibst du ja auch immer wieder oder führst interessante Interviews. Also danke dir, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, hier für den Rasenfunk.
Wollte ich mir doch nicht entgehen lassen, hier nochmal schnell über den SVWW sprechen zu können.
Ja, ja, ja, jetzt mal abwarten, jetzt mal abwarten. Wir werden das alles in Ruhe sehen und können ja dann auch bewerten, wie es für die Vereine ausgegangen ist. Und euch lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, danke ich natürlich für eure Aufmerksamkeit und für euren Support, denn der Rasenfunk, er ist und bleibt werbefrei. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Stefan, bei Telehammer, bei Sintram, bei Christoph M bei Philipp und bei ColdSievers. Sie alle haben uns nicht nur unterstützt, sondern sie haben sich auch registriert als supporter in den Rasenfunk.de slash-Supporters-Club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Kreditkarte, Paypal, Banküberweisung, alles ist möglich und davon zahlen wir alles, was hier im Rasenfunk stattfindet, inklusive ein kleines Honorar an all unsere Gäste. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Unterstützung, bleibt gesund, bleibt im Rasenfunk gewogen, empfiehlt uns weiter und bis bald.
Das war der Rasenfunk, von Ihnen unterstützt, herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.